okay so we're continuing to flesh out
our understanding of that Trump Tower
meeting that took place involving Trump
campaign officials and Russian agents
including attorney in Italia vessel
Mnet's kaya and initially we learned a
meeting happened right but we were told
no one really knew what it was about it
wasn't specifically to get help with the
election we weren't we weren't really
sure that there were Russians the people
that were meeting with us and that it
related to the campaign we didn't really
know about it in advance there was no
follow-up to the meeting
nothing Berger was a term that was
advanced by Trump's cronies and people
on the right over time we've learned
that most of that stuff wasn't true we
learned that the meeting was very much
an anticipated it was very much planned
that Donald Trump personally likely knew
about it and approved of it that it was
specifically to get dirt on Hillary
Clinton from a foreign power and that it
represented the intent to accept things
of value from foreign countries for the
purposes of winning an American election
criminally speaking it doesn't matter
whether or not they got the dirt what
matters is that they were willing to and
they met and they very well could have
gotten that dirt had it been provided at
that meeting by those Russian actors
that's what we knew before today the new
news is that a series of very
suspiciously timed money transfers have
been identified that took place both
right after the Trump Tower meeting and
right after the election of Donald Trump
in 2016 and those are now being
investigated very closely and this
relates to a Ross Aguila Roth who was
involved in a series of money transfers
from overseas accounts to move money
from Russia and Switzerland to the
British Virgin Islands Bangkok and an
office park in New Jersey right after
that Trump Tower meeting and two of the
recipients of those funds were
participants
in the Trump Tower meeting for federal
law enforcement officials said to
BuzzFeed news that there were two bursts
of what they're calling banking activity
one right after the Trump Tower meeting
the other right after Donald Trump's
election that are being looked at in
detail one of the accounts in question
belongs to Amin a gala Roth who's the
son of a Ross a gala of he was involved
in the planning of this meeting that
account had been dormant since 2015 when
the money first started coming in money
was also sent to an account belonging to
a company connected to Rob Goldstone
Goldstone is the publicist for Amin a
gala Roth who were originally excuse me
who originally set up the Trump Tower
meeting one of those transfers took
place eleven days after the meeting and
was for nineteen point five million
dollars from an offshore company owned
by a gala of to his account at a bank in
none other than New York City these of
course could be just coincidental
transactions involving the people
connected to that meeting taking place
just after the meeting going to bank
accounts in the exact location where the
meeting took place but do we really
believe in those coincidences at this
point and I want to be clear just
because something is suspicious doesn't
mean that there was wrongdoing or that
there was criminality but it is another
angle in this entire investigation and
following the money is often a really
smart way to go about this type of
investigation and of course if this all
had nothing to do with the presidential
election nor the Trump Tower meeting or
any of it
we should ultimately be able to figure
out the sort of benign and totally
aboveboard reasons why such massive
amounts of money we're moving in this
way and with this schedule involving the
people who were connected to that
meeting will we ever get those answers I
don't know I don't know but in the
meantime the drip drip drip continues
and nothing exculpatory or even
eventually exculpatory has surfaced so
far that's what we keep sometimes
missing in terms of missing the forest
for the trees where there will be some
story related to Trump Russia and the
defenders will say this isn't 100%
verifiable proof of wrongdoing fair
enough it's part of the investigation
now but nothing has taken place in the
last what's has it been a year and a
half at this point two years nearly of
at least suspicion about this stuff
no big exculpatory events have taken
place and that is something that the
trumpets simply don't talk about they
will take any individual story and say
this source isn't the most trustworthy
or this isn't definitive evidence of a
crime or no one has been indicted for
this particular thing so far that may
all be true but wouldn't you think that
if all of this stuff were bogus that
after a year and a half or more we would
have had some major exculpatory moment
and instead we haven't had that we've
had more evidence building piles and
pyramids and concentric circles of
evidence now what do I think big picture
is the ultimate reality of the Russia
story I've been getting more and more
emails from people saying David I get
the day-to-day reporting about what's
going on but what's the big picture here
like what do you think took place I
think the most likely scenario is that
Donald Trump's involvement with rich
Russians started a long time ago and it
started with Trump as sort of the useful
idiot it started with rich Russians
using Trump to launder and legitimize
their wealth outside of Russia in
particular mostly through real estate
transactions this led to conversations
about Trump having trouble getting loans
from sort of more reputable financial
institutions funny to even call them
that but more reputable I guess than
random dudes in Russia and that ended up
with Trump doing more financial business
with the Russians and he essentially got
in too deep and
could be in too deep out of ignorance
and greed the oleg arks ended up using
him and they happened to be Putin
connected and it slid into what
ultimately took place in the 2016
election beyond that it's details right
which parts were criminal was trump
willing or coerced in his involvement
those are the only questions that really
remain but I think that that is roughly
the big picture of what it is that took
place here I want to hear from you
though what do you think is the big
picture aside from the Trump Russia
meeting Rosneft alpha bank Natalya
vessel Mnet's kaya all the details
stepping back what do you think is the
big picture of Trump Russia I am on
Instagram at David Pakman a lot of
exciting behind-the-scenes and political
stuff happening there and make sure also
to follow the David Pakman show on
Instagram we now have our own Instagram
account we are publishing video clips
there we are on instagram at david
pakman show quick break the homeopathy
debunking episode of the pseudoscience
miniseries is coming up next I think
most people are going to like this one
one of today's sponsors is Skillshare
which is an amazing online learning
community that offers thousands of high
quality classes on almost any topic the
first 500 people will click the link
under this video we'll get to entire
months of totally free access to every
single class offered by Skillshare
they've got classes on everything design
video editing photography business
technology cooking meditation even
classes on how to become a more
productive person I know you'll be able
to find something on Skillshare that
fascinates you or will help you with
something in your everyday life classes
are taught by real people who care about
what they're teaching I just took a
really great class on more advanced
video editing techniques the david
pakman show is giving you two months of
free access to every class they offer
when you click the link under this video
I mean really just think about
everything that you'll have at your
fingertips for two whole months totally
free that's hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep have
access to every class on Skillshare for
less than 10 bucks a month it's one of
the most affordable learning platforms
out there just click the link under this
video to redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry because it's only
available to the first 500 people who
sign up